more on this now let's join
with texas dps lieutenant chris olaveres
lieutenant i was with you for the last
10 plus days we saw it but your reaction
to the news now that mexico has
effectively given the almost 15 000
strong caravan a pass to head straight
to the border across from you
good afternoon griff so that just goes
to show you right there that there's no
accountability or they're not even
fulfilling their agreement to stop these
caravans
from making it to the u.s border but we
do know for a fact grip when we see
these caravans we know they're gonna
break off and branch off into smaller
groups and that's when the smuggling
organizations take over and for the most
part we'll probably see most of these
individuals try to make it to the path
of least resistance some of these
sectors which is eagle pass and del rio
where we're going to see the majority of
these immigrants try to make their way
across you know into that sector but
again you know we're out here this
morning again it's it's been non-stop
you were out here with us this past week
and you saw all the activity in the
rogandy valley sector the single dollar
surrounders the ones that were always
constantly talked about and how it's
just overwhelming for border patrol and
how it's essential to have dps and
national guard out there with them to
provide that support
i was there through thursday on that
morning there at the adult port of entry
you had 22 pounds of fentanyl
apprehended that's enough fentanyl to
kill five million americans according to
the dea let me show our viewers
lieutenant if i can what the border
patrol chief role ortiz put out just
this week
alone
the entire u.s border 800 plus pounds of
cocaine almost 500 pounds of meth almost
200 pounds of marijuana 16 sex offenders
two gang members two felons two
murderers lieutenant do americans fully
understand
what is coming across our border
wall griff you know at some point uh in
some in some perspective i believe they
don't and that's why it's very important
especially when there's coverage showing
what's actually taking place and it was
a good example when you're out here with
us and actually being out there you know
on the ground and showing what's taking
place bill mollusion has done it
numerous times ever since last year and
it really puts it in perspective what's
taking place because actually showing
the hard work you know from border
patrol dps troopers national guard
actually chasing down these single
adults these runners and also these
large groups that are coming across and
the drugs and the criminals that are
coming across but it's a it's a
compounding effect when you have when
you see mass migration because what
comes with that is again as i mentioned
the single adults the runners the
criminals the drugs that are coming
through the ports of entry and how it
affects not only the state of texas but
it affects the entire uh country so
again it just it's just going back to
showing how essential it is and
providing that perspective to the
american people what's really taking
place along the southern border
lieutenant this past week we saw vice
president harris travel out to the
league of nations out to california and
pledge nearly two billion dollars for
the root causes in that northern
triangle central american countries of
honduras el salvador and guatemala but
is it your view that maybe some more of
those resources need to be where you are
at ground zero in the border to address
the unprecedented crisis
well well graph you know allocating all
these you know billions of dollars you
know to these northern you know triangle
countries where 90 percent of the
immigrants that are coming across our
border are from those northern triangle
countries to include mexico so it has
not done anything to slow down the what
we're seeing now as far as mass
migration and the single dollars and the
criminals and the drugs are coming
across so they need to divert those
resources those funds to the southern
border where they're needed but it's not
it's more than just money it's more than
just funding they need to enact those
policies that were effective you know
prior to 2021 that was working and
that's what they need to do right now is
actually focus on those policies you
know as far as enacting those policies
what's working and provide that support
to border patrol because they need it
right now
lieutenant
chris oliveiras i want to commend you
after the nearly two weeks i spent with
you and lieutenant cassarez lupe and
everybody down there despite these
surging numbers you've gone out every
single day before the sun comes up and
gone after them and i know the morale is
perhaps suffering but you've stayed
strong well done
sir thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight